a
[Música]
en un país donde la población es
mayoritariamente joven el kobe 19 parece
tomar fuerza cada día según los datos de
organismos independientes y es que
mientras el gobierno mantiene un bloqueo
a la información demográfica de los
contagios en el país el observatorio
ciudadano registra que entre los jóvenes
es donde se está presentando la mayor
cantidad de contagios en nicaragua según
esta iniciativa ciudadana en el grupo
poblacional de personas entre 30 y 39
años se han registrado en las últimas
semanas más de 840 casos con una tasa de
mortalidad del 5 por ciento mientras en
el grupo de entre 20 a 29 años se está
registrando en las últimas semanas más
de 600 casos en nicaragua hasta hoy no
se ha restringido la movilidad ni se ha
enviado algún tipo de cuarentena y es
común ver los centros comerciales los
bares y los restaurantes repletos de
personas
[Música]
según la sociedad chilena de medicina
intensiva de los más de 10 mil 300
fallecidos por kobe que existían en
chile- las primeras semanas de agosto
sólo 42 personas eran menores de 20 años
como ha ocurrido en otros lugares del
mundo en la cob y también ha sido mucho
más compacidad con los sectores más más
jóvenes de la población que han
registrado tasas de mortalidad menores a
otros sectores de edad no así con sus
efectos psicológicos según un reciente
estudio del instituto nacional de
juventud y de la universidad cátolica
los jóvenes es decir aquella población
menor de 29 años son los que sufren con
más fuerza los efectos psicológicos de
la pandemia inquietud ansiedad estrés
insomnio son algunos de los síntomas que
reportan con más fuerza los jóvenes
según esta encuesta un 40 por ciento de
ellos afirma que no tenía muchas ganas
de hacer nada la preocupación y el
estrés y la ansiedad marcan también este
sector de la población que ve que su
situación laboral va a ser mucho más
difícil en un futuro cercano marcado por
los estragos económicos que deja tras de
sí la pandemia
[Música]
cuando empezó la pandemia turquía impuso
una de las medidas más restrictivas
contra sus jóvenes menores de 20 años el
gobierno de recep tayyp erdogán les
prohibió terminantemente salir de sus
casas bajo ningún concepto ni para poder
ir al supermercado exceptuando si eran
mayores de 18 y tenían un trabajo al que
asistir desde entonces de los meses más
difíciles de pandemia turquía relajado
estas medidas pero sin embargo obliga a
terminantemente que todos sus ciudadanos
si salen de casa lleven mascarilla y en
las calles de turquía y de estambul no
se vea casi nadie se más quería entre
ellos los jóvenes las discotecas y los
bares nocturnos están cerrados y los
bares por las tardes si tienen comida sí
que pueden abrir y estos están llenos de
jóvenes sin embargo una vez se levantan
de sus sillas todos se ponen la
mascarilla para ir a cualquier sitio por
la calle
[Música]